I don't know if I can do this oh I'd
really like to go back in time and punch
myself for thinking this was a good idea
every year there is a worldwide
challenge called National Novel Writing
Month also known as NaNoWriMo and this
takes place every year during the month
of November and the challenge is to
write 50,000 words in those 30 days
absolutely ridiculous and absurd and
crazy so of course I'm gonna do it but
I'm taking on this challenge because I
am a type of person who never finishes
anything so maybe if I've logged the
entire thing and I do this I can
actually finish a book in 30 days it is
two days away from November but I've
already written an outline I have a
pretty good idea of the story I'm going
to write and hopefully I can do this
wish me luck so theoretically I should
write 1667 words a day to get to 50,000
by the end of the month but
realistically that's probably not gonna
happen so today my goal is 3,000 words
trying to start off strong because I
know later in the month I'm not gonna do
as well
okay it's been about an hour and a half
and I have written two thousand two
hundred and eighty nine words what's up
I'm going to an official NaNoWriMo event
later today and I'm gonna write so much
more I broke five thousand words today
which is way more than I was planning
and way more than I anticipated I got my
coffee ready to rock ready to be
energized I'm officially done for the
day because I just wrote three thousand
two hundred and twenty three words which
brings me to a total of eight thousand
two hundred and ninety one words on day
two I am on fire
so it's somehow day six not sure how I
got here I wrote a little over two
thousand words today and it was kind of
a struggle to get there this is the
first time I've just kind of hit a wall
I wrote over 4,000 words today which is
pretty damn good
I've been significantly slowing down in
my writing process I don't know why it's
just been really hard to hit even like a
thousand words I don't know if I can do
this after a very long time of just
excruciating writer's block
I have finally reached 25,000 words I'm
halfway there guys I'm half way there I
realized today that I haven't really
told you what my books about so
basically I'm writing a young adult
fantasy novel and the story follows two
twins and they discover this circular
room full of seven doors and they learn
that each door leads to a different
world it would be like if one door led
to Narnia one door led to Hogwarts so
the twins go through these doors and
they go on this crazy adventure and I'm
not gonna tell you anything more than
that but feel like at the end of this
month I'll at least have some very fun
of something to work with because before
any of this all it was was an idea Lily
sighs oh I haven't written in five days
why do I keep doing this why does this
keep happening all right this is it this
is the last straw it is November 20th
I'm gonna write every day I'm gonna do
this I'm gonna do this I'm going to do
this okay so this is becoming a
recurring thing for me Thanksgiving
break was a thing and I went home to see
my family I had a great time but I
didn't write a single word so I haven't
written in about six days it's November
27th
I have literally four days to finish
this book this whole time I was like
this is hard I'm struggling but I can do
it I'm gonna do this and now I'm getting
to the point or I don't know if I can do
this okay we're at the very last
NaNoWriMo event we are pretty much the
last people here
look at this look at this look at this
homestretch now it's the home stretch we
can do this let's go I'm gonna do it for
the first time this month I am
officially confident enough to say that
I am going to finish NaNoWriMo and going
to write 50,000 words in 30 days and it
feels so good to say that I just hit 45
thousand words and tomorrow is the last
day which means I have to write 5,000
words tomorrow and that's it oh my god
this is such an incredible feeling I
can't even explain it to you it's I'm so
proud today is the last day of NaNoWriMo
I have a little bit less than 5,000
words left I think I can do it that
seems pretty reasonable in one day and
once today is over I will have written
50,000 words that I will be done oh my
god 38 words left
[Music]
ready those words that's worth fifty
thousand words
technically fifty thousand and eleven
words oh my god
I honestly cannot believe that this is
over what an incredible experience
honestly like challenging myself to do
this was so hard but really fun for the
parts that it wasn't killing me it was
really fun and to celebrate I'm gonna go
print out my entire book so that I can
hold it in my hands and just physically
see my accomplishment I have it this is
still pretty awesome to be able to hold
this in my hand and say I wrote all of
it oh my god Oh actually holding this so
many pages what the heck how did you do
this where did you do this I don't get
it moving forward I think I'm going to
read my entire thing edit it fix all the
very sloppy mistakes that I'm sure I
made while I was trying to just push
through these 30 days and then I'm gonna
find an editor maybe find an agent not
sure how to do that but it's gonna
happen and maybe hopefully one day my
book will be in your local book store
but honestly this was such a great
experience I'm so excited for everyone
else who participated in NaNoWriMo and
everyone else who completed it and
finished their goal like that's so hard
good for you high five team maybe I'll
see you again next year NaNoWriMo
[Music]